ah ah
[Musique]
encore
comme on se retrouve tu te rappelles de
thomas qui a traversé le temps avec le
robot kb 28 ou plutôt elliott comme il
aime se faire appeler monsieur ils sont
à la recherche d'iris et ça tombe bien
car il la retrouve saine et sauve assise
sur un trône dans un château au
moyen-âge pas le genre d'endroit où tu
recroise une ex n'est ce pas thomas lice
thomas
mais qu'est ce que tu fous là avant toi
toi que tu fous là
iris il y a un problème attendez
pourquoi le robot à café de mon père et
mon ex se retrouve au moyen-âge dans mon
château sont justement plusieurs te voir
ici marc l connaissez-vous c'est un truc
voulez vous qu'on les élimine sur le
champ oui oui temps robin non non oui je
les connais et non les tu vas rire mais
je pense que c'est que tu m'avais qui
paie au t'es juste comme c'est
une autre époque
ne t'inquiète pas mâché je te ramène
dans le présent dans le latin je voulais
éviter cette situation désolé
d'interrompre les retrouvailles iris
il y a un problème avec le dr ciel a
tant qu'abbé 28 tu as dit quoi sur mon
père héros et nappez ou tomber dans une
autre époque on s'en fout le plus
important c'est que on est ensemble ou
retournent chez nous thomas on n'est
plus ensemble les risques ou le docteur
simon a disparu
kb 28 c'est normal que mon père ait
disparu il voyage dans le temps à
tricher il a inventé la machine
il s'en sert s'énoncer c'est qu'on
comprend pas thomas je sais que ça doit
te faire un choc mais oui je viens du
futur et je voyage d'époque en ait pour
tous je reviens pas tu voulais pas te le
dire ni plomb coupe sa capacité à
accepter le voyage dans le temps est
impossible dans un boulot
c'est pas de l'osce et de l'onu iris ton
père a vraiment disparu tous ceux qui
voyagent laisse des traces temporel on
peut les localiser et voir par où ils
sont passés mais le docteur simon plus
rien impossible de savoir où il est je
crois que mon père est est décédé et ben
moi je ne trouve que toi avec ta robe de
rennes non je pense qu'il est encore en
vie j'ai été activée à distance par ton
père j'ai pensé que c'était pour tous
ceux qui servent à café je les chercher
mais il était introuvable au laboratoire
j'ai pris la dernière machine à voyager
dans le temps pour essayer de le
localiser
impossible alors je me suis dit que tu
savais peut-être aussi l'état attendait
la statue qui brille pas bouger là vous
avez un chevalier en armure gib à rennes
je peut l'éliminer d'un coup d'épée soul
et c'est très tentant j'avoue mais non
kb 28 je vais vérifier ton histoire dans
machine à voyager dans les quartiers
suivants et macchabées 28
il s'appelle elliott d'abord sinon c'est
le robot pob parce que je sais plus
pourquoi c'est pas une machine à qui on
donne des ordres
elia tu peux me porter sur ton dos de
sol un peu bouger ton taux d'alcoolémie
très élevé montrent thomas c'est bien
gentil machine
j'ai pas une nouvelle de mon père depuis
un moment tu sais qu'on s'entend pas
très bien peut-être que ma machine pour
à le localiser plus facilement
[Musique]
aliénor marraine vous ici tu fais quoi
ici tu dois nettoyer les latrines pas ma
chambre je passe juste un coup de
plumeau rien de plus mais je m'en vais à
leur look d'homme lyrisme et tient la
machine dans son dos je ne veux trouver
quoi à l'énorme masse a tout de suite tu
as maigri j'ai percé votre secret c'est
à cause de vous et de cet objet magique
que les malheurs sont tombés sur mon
mari et moi-même rend ma machine avant
de faire une connerie vous êtes démunis
désormais je vais pouvoir récupérer mon
trône en pressant les boutons de cette
boîte machika gonnord maintenant danie
royer l'homme était vous à genoux et
demandez moi partons pour l'injure que
vous avez porté un autre familier aux là
bas mais les parties de malcom et
c'était les porter avec ma machine
c'était qui aliénor de castille la reine
du château est là les bulls
quand je suis arrivé j'ai fait
emprisonner le roi et je lui ai filé un
brevet revente et je regrette parce que
cette cote a pris ma machine me suis
bien fait pour ta gueule de la chose
quand je ne peux plus être le ter j'ai
quelque chose qui peut le réveiller ah
oui c'est vrai que tu fais des cafés ça
va lui faire les fêtes
- vous parlez c'est pour toi t'es pas en
l'état there c'est encore mieux
depuis quand tu as hâte je me suis
ajouter cette fonctionnalité avant de
partir
camélia tape une tueuse signal akt
écoute chez nous volontiers c'est
vraiment le moment
bon un équipement très bien le dessin
d'une fleur dans la crème seline e à
bercy bon alors bon on va devoir
utiliser ta machine pour retrouver mon
père est ce que tu as des traces de lui
avant sa disparition oui il a beaucoup
changé d'époque avant de disparaître
mais j'ai tout enregistrer parfait voilà
ce qu'on va faire 11 barque du moyen âge
on dépose thomas chez sa mère à son
époque voit ensuite on suit les traces
de mon père on cherche des informations
ce qui faisait avec qui il échangeait
peut-être que ça nous mènera à lui que
mon saut je rentre chez moi c'est
dangereux de voyager dans le temps et
wavre agents suis pas capable c'est ça
je peux être super utile et en même
temps on peut en profiter pour clarifier
notre situation ce moment je vois que tu
t'en fous de mon père et que tu veux
juste être avec moi assez ton père qu'on
cherche
ah bah oui j'étais bourré je suis
l'homme de la situation pour retrouver
ton père qui doit être quelqu'un d'autre
charmant c'est un coup comment tu parles
de nouveau bien désolé de vous
l'apprendre comme ça mais j'ai plus
assez de batteries pour voyager dans le
temps
ah non ne me dis pas qu on est coincé
ici et j'ai puisé dans mes réserves
avec montazer voilà ça c'est une mission
pour moi tu veux voir je suis
indispensable
alors oui on peut savoir ce que tu fais
là mais privat mais tout bien qu'il ait
pas de prises ici on est en 1314 alors
je sais j'ai vu ça dans un documentaire
la télé on pas sur le toit du numérique
en effet de l'orage on met un câble
entre l'antenne et illies haute
on attend qu'il fasse un homme marié ça
c'est le film retour vers le futur
iris a tué à petit objet électronique ça
suffirait largement me j'ai un téléphone
portable
je les filets au roi en échange de son
royaume il est dans les cachots
[Musique]
lâcher son royaume en échange d'un
téléphone d'un foyer des vidéos pornos
dessus talent rendu dingue dès qu'il m'a
filé sa place je les paie emprisonnés et
j'ai réduit la reine en esclavage on y
attend
je regarde du port louis où toutes les
filles les filles du futur regard du
porno non plus les filles regardé par
nous mais nous dans le futur rôle des
fois non il faut frapper avant tout
frais c'est moi ou le roi son pantalon
baissé
parce que là je vois tout ça je sais
qu'il fallait frapper à la porte on
encore merci marraine pour la pierre
plate magique et les images de femmes
qui est-ce qui peut remonter son poteau
par ses iris
c'étaient les polisseurs à la faire
selon un témoin le ciblage
je veux voir les femmes seront voirie
c'est horrible ce que du feu roi
découvrir le porno arrivé juste après ça
peut faire très mal
les révoltés mais pourquoi ils se
révoltent d'un coup là cette chanson
qu'ils ont appris ce qu'ils auront bien
révolutionnaire oui c'est ma chanson oui
je peux être utile que les gens
m'écoutent pas du tout ils veulent vous
couper la tête
ils se détestent cette chanson en plus
c'est en partie pour ça que j'ai quitté
ton époque tout comme toujours ensemble
c'est bon j'ai fait de la batterie du
téléphone on peut quitter cette époque
enfin une bonne nouvelle mon cher roi
j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer que
vous récupérez votre royaume à l'école
un royaume ne m'intéresse pas je veux le
pire pelote avec le fameux
révolutionnaire y arrive ils ont déjà
exécuté la moitié des châteaux ils vont
pas démerdez-vous un immense casse kbr
elliott
oui allez mon père j'ai quelque chose à
berlin en 1944 non bon bah c'est parti
comment peut-il vraiment nul en histoire
mais bon ça va je me lâche pas dans le
temps proposent tous ces trucs mans il
suffit d'aller à l'école martin elliott
casse on nous tient droit
il reste 2 % de bassines à mr
on est sacralisé la trace temporelle des
auteurs ciment resté près de moi
direction l'allemagne au tampon
ralisation immédiate
on va c'est parti
[Musique]
oui c'est la guerre en fait bien vite
marre c'est même la seconde guerre
mondiale comme on l'apprend dans le
programme de 4e désormais chers
auditeurs tu en sais plus sur la quête
d'elliot il faut retrouver le docteur
simon inventeur de la machine à voyager
dans le temps
bon il le retrouver écoute le prochain
épisode
moi je sais déjà tout je te le dis on
vous libère vous êtes libre tout va
mieux vous avez votre image
merci d'avoir écouté le deuxième épisode
de l'épopée temporel n'hésite pas à ta
bonne et à mettre un pouce en l'air et à
la semaine prochaine